Hello, everyone!
So excited to be here!
At CSSconf and talk to you about the algorithms
of CSS.
What is this talk going to be about?
So, hello!
So my name is Lara Schenck, and that's my
Twitter handle.
I'm a freelance WordPress and front-end developer
in WordPress and CSS are my two loves, as
well as teaching.
I love teaching been are sharing what I know,
and using teaching as a means to get myself
to to learn things which is kind of what I
did with this talk.
So, CSS: it has a special place in my heart
as I'm sure it does for most of us here.
I have a background in art.
I came upon CSS through a weird college project
- art project - where I wanted it to turn
it into a video game which morphed into making
WordPress sites pour money which turned into
- for money which turned into a career I love.
Computer science didn't turn up in my career
until three years ago or so.
I got good at making websites but didn't understand
what was happening under the surface.
This showed up in the form of an algorithms
interview.
How many of us have done an algorithms whiteboarding
interview before?
Good amount of hands.
Questionable interviewing stale but it exists.
So, that was my first encounter.
I definitely failed it, and then about a year
ago I got an interview for a job I was excited
about.
I thought I've got to take this one seriously,
and I've got to learn about computer science.
So I really grew to love it.
The connection between computer science and
CSS wasn't always clear.
Like I saw the connections between my work
with JavaScript and with PHP quite often,
but with CSS, it was hard to bridge that gap.
So, in the spirit of committing to teach things
in order to learn them, I proposed this talk
for CSSconf EU.
And I started my research for this about six
months ago, and CSS really went from something
like this - so grey, like I was got to write
CSS, it is not as interesting as the other
programming stuff I'm doing - and then over
the six months of research, CSS became like,
"Oh, my God, CSS is so cool.
The dream!
This is awesome."
In addition to those kind of like revitalisation
of my love for CSS, my code got better and
intentional, and I write code faster.
I want to share with you how I got to that
point in my journey in this research.
To I started all of this with a question:
is CSS a programming language?
How many of you have thought about this before?
Good, nice number of hands.
I want to follow up this with a fire emoji
because this is a hot topic lately.
I posed this question on Twitter: is CSS a
programming language?
The results were about as expected: 42 per
cent, no; 50 per cent - or rather 42 per cent,
yes; 50 per cent, no; eight per cent, I'm
not sure.
The responses to the tweet were, "The yeses
were absolutely, it is a programming language.
For sure."
And the noes were more like, "You can't really
call programming a web page layout, you don't
say you programme in CSS."
It's not what it is like.
I mulled this over and thought, stop.
I think we might be get some opinions, and
like personal experience mixed up with facts
here.
So let's start by asking what is a programming
language?
Ground breaking it definition coming up: a
language of instructions for a computer.
The thing is, the definition of a programming
language is kind of intentionally vague.
There are many, many types of programming
languages.
Soon after reading about the definition of
a programming limitation, one would encounter
programming paradigms, and the term "paradigm"
is really a word for a general classification
or model or style of doing something, and
there are two main classifications in programming
paradigms: imperative programming paradigm
which refers to code that tells a computer
how to do something.
And there is declarative, which is code that
tells a computer what to do.
So these are two fundamentally different paradigms,
and they're the two main umbrellas.
With paradigms, languages can be characterised
under paradigms or can be described as styles
of the code you're writing.
You might be writing JavaScript in a more
declarative or imperative style.
And the two, or rather the main difference
between imperative and declarative languages
is the presence of control flow in imperative
languages which refers to the ability to manipulate
the order of execution of statements in a
programme, and that happens via, like if statements
and for loops.
In a literal sense, your computer would read
the programme top to bottom, and declarative
programming does not have control flow, so
any logic or iteration is kind of baked into
the actual instructions themes, or what you're
telling the computer to do is declarative.
Languages that fall under these categories.
Imperative are we think of programming languages:
JavaScript, Ruby, C++, Python.
Generally, if you think of a programming language,
it is an imperative language.
Declarative languages are oftentimes domain-specific.
Which means they've been to develop within
a certain context within a certain domain.
What are some domain-specific languages?
SQL is one.
It is a domain-specific declarative limitation
for working with databases.
HTML.
What?
Sure!
HTML is a domain-specific language.
And, of course, CSS!
Okay, sure there are people who would be,
"What are you talking about?
Just no.
CSS is not.
Doesn't count."
Whether you want to argue CSS was never intended
to be something like a programming language
or perhaps that the browser can't really count,
it just parses, it doesn't do anything else,
to that I would say that CSS plus HTML is
Turing-complete, which is the ability to solve
a problem of a certain complexity.
CSS can do math, which is cool.
Functions and variables, CSS also has.
Ultimately, I would say why not?
So why can't CSS and HTML be part of what
we consider programming languages?
So, the idea of disqualifying HTML and CSS
leads to disqualifying all of declarative
languages, so I think that discrepancy comes
into play when people are misinterpreting
what comparative versus declarative is.
Further, the web at large is declarative in
nature.
If we had to describe in our programmes how
a computer is supposed to, or how a browser
is supposed to open a connection to a server,
that would be intense and totally inaccessible,
so the power of declarative programming is
huge especially when it comes to APIs and
anything we do on the web.
So, hear this loud and clear: CSS is a domain-specific
declarative programming language 100 per cent.
And another one: we as CSS developers programme
the layout of web pages.
I will give that another 100 per cent.
Given to what I do as a CSS developer as programmer
is getting used to that.
As I get more and more used to how a browser
works, the code can totally count as programming.
Now we've established, got that out of the
way, let's talk about algorithms.
Algorithms 101.
Yay!
Let's have another definition.
It is a well-defined computational procedure
that takes input and produces output.
This is a definition taken from the introduction
to algorithms, which is one of these large
text books I a signed for computer science
courses, dense, informative, maybe not a great
intro, but hopefully this will be.
Let's use this framework to talk about algorithms.
We have inputs.
Unsorted list, and we have outputs - maybe
a sorted list.
What is the algorithm in between there?
Well, sorting is certainly a solved problem
in computer science.
We've lots of sorting algorithms - bubble
sort is one.
A great name.
Not the most performant of sorting algorithms,
but it is the excellent.
Selection sort.
We also have merge sort.
And quick sort.
Let's take a look at implementation of one
of these to kind of take a look at what an
algorithm is under the hood.
So, when I - bubble sort, this is what a sorting
algorithm looks like if anybody has ever seen
one.
Let's read for a moment.
Wonderful bubble sort in all of its glory.
This is imperative JavaScript here.
We're telling the computer how to sort.
We're giving it step by step instructions
to be read top down and the control flow is
there so we're jumping back up to certain
statements where necessary.
It's
this word "declarative programme", this is
all you would see.
Back to our framework.
How would algorithms, or algorithmic thinking
like this, apply to CSS?
Let's say we have a stack of elements, and
our output would be a row of elements.
What would be an algorithm we would use in
declarative CSS to get there?
What would be an algorithm we would use to
get there?
Display flex - sure, why not?
That's totally an algorithm.
Or perhaps flow left.
Gasp!
Let's take a close look at the implementation
of this algorithm.
Okay.
Just like there it is.
Display flex.
That's declarative CSS.
I will give us a heart, because that's amazing
that we can just - that's display flex.
Okay, I did a ton of stuff and I didn't have
to write that code, that how.
That's the power of declarative programming.
It's kind of the dream, I think, with what
we do with CSS.
So the thing is, there is of course a how
to declarative programmes.
We write the what, at we need to understand
the how to make our code better.
Let's have an iceberg metaphor.
So, declarative on the top, and imperative
on the bottom.
When it comes to CSS, the imperative part
is going to be our - the declarative part
is going to be our iceberg at the top, and
the C++ and Rust code that lies within a browser's
rendering engine is what we have at the bottom.
I was like I want to look at this imperative
CSS, what is there?
I started taking a look at the cascade.
I love the cascade in CSS.
Not only is the cascade wonderful but the
first thing that shows up when you search
algorithms and CSS.
It combines property values from different
source that is from Mozilla developer network.
If we place this into our algorithms framework,
we start with inputs from different sources,
and our outputs.
What is the difference in between in we sort
by origin, specificity, and the origin specified.
The winning value is what it sent to the browser's
rendering engine.
So I understood the cascade, like this is
not ground breaking information.
I'm guessing a lot of us here understand the
cascade.
I wanted to see what it looked like and I
expected to find something like function cascade
- magic.
And that's pretty much what I found.
Like function cascade.
Look at it.
It's right there!
So the thing is, this is more of like a fun
slide, because the cascade happens in hundreds
of, maybe thousands of lines of code throughout
the source of CSS but you can't pinpoint it
to one file.
This was like growing in size.
Where did I find this code?
I know you're dying to spend the weekend looking
through Rust and C++.
So we can go to searchfox.org, as well as
cs.chromium.org which is the searchable repository
of chromium.
We want to look at the rendering engine.
In Firefox, it is called Serveo, and in Chrome,
called Blink.
That's also used in Opera.
My process for looking through these source
files was to read the spec carefully, and
I would go step by step through this and map
what I was reading in the spec to the source
code which was a nice process.
Browser source code aimlessly gets a little
bit tedious.
Another thing I want to point out is that
became like way more apparent and meaningful
were the simple names of what we call in CSS.
We are all familiar with the idea of selector
property and value but this is called a declaration.
I often call this a rule, and this whole thing
is called a rule, and it's really important
to, or rather these terms became way more
meaningful after it had the experience of
looking through the browser, because the CSS
is parse ed specifically to retrieve each
of these values.
So, whatever, the cascade exists in the browser.
Got it.
This is when my CSS, this is when I had this
enlightenment moment where I was like CSS,
and I was like oh, my God, so cool, I see
the stuff happening underneath.
This is wonderful.
So, I think that's where every line of code
I would write, "I see this other part," and
it was just amazing.
So I suggested for everybody, a specific example
to get back to the algorithm a little bit
more, and about how my code and my style of
writing could change after.
This was a wonderful mock-up I received from
one of my clients.
... so the bottom would be transparent, the
top would be like opaque, and then all the
sideways would be, and what not.
So I started coding this.
Everything was great, and then I was like,
the ratios are really different, and mobile
versus the desktop, this is frustrating.
A fun challenge but I'm getting annoyed.
I began programming my CSS with a hammer,
so if like anybody is sure we've done this
before, where you're like work!
And you're trying the ten things.
Maybe it will work this time.
So, I was like, okay, stop.
Don't do that.
I'm writing this whole talk about algorithms,
and like algorithmic thinking in CSS.
What if I break this down into an algorithms
problem?
So what are the inputs?
Beautiful ocean image number one.
Beautiful ocean image number two, and my viewport
of course.
What are the outputs?
As CSS developers, we are programmers of boxes.
What position will those be?
I had to write an algorithm for this.
How do I write an algorithm?
I've been studying for these ridiculous whiled
boarding interviews, here are the steps that
you take.
You plan your inputs and outputs.
What steps you're going to take in between.
You come one a brute force solution, and your
brute force solution is a not performant solution
for the algorithm, you're getting it done
and getting it work.
With something like brute force serve, you
would rather than algorithmically or efficiently
group certain elements and search in a more
strategised way, you would go step by step,
like is this the one?
No.
That's the idea of brute force.
Third step, you would walk through, so like
check and see how your algorithm works.
Fourth step, optimise your solution.
Apply different strategies for algorithms
designed to whatever your brute-force solution
was and refactor it.
Great.
So plan, talked about the inputs and outputs
already.
I took to my white board and figured out how
I wanted these boxes to change at different
view port sizes, and then came back and mapped
out different values and behaviours I wanted
for this specific layout.
Then I jumped into some serial code.
I was like, okay.
I was like serial code for CSS?
Cool.
That's not something I usually do but this
is really helpful.
So then number 2, I would go to my brute force
solution, and another word for that is spaghetti!
Like spaghetti code.
This is when this brute-force accept is when
you have permission to write bad code.
It is indicate, I don't have to think about
the naming conventions, I want to figure out
the solution to a problem.
I had never approached CSS that way.
It's how I approach JavaScript and - brute
force CSS, what have we got?
Smelly CSS!
So some qualities of brute force CSS.
Is it part of a system?
No.
If you're working within a design system,
I'm not sure how many of us have the luxury
of coining that.
Scrap your design system for a second.
Got to figure out a weird problem, not going
to do it in the confines this system as it's
a hindrance right now.
Magic numbers?
Absolutely.
To do comments.
Does it work?
Absolutely.
Figuring it out, it might work.
Step three.
Walk-through.
This is when we can do the wonderful browser
resizing that we developers love to do.
Not sure if users do that but we love to do
it.
Make note of what works and doesn't.
Fourth step: optimise our brute force CSS
and refactor.
"Optimise" is a word for refactor.
We take our smelly CSS which magically transforms
into a beautiful flower.
A flower of optimised CSS!
[Applause].
I might have had the most fun making this
slide.
Optimised CSS, what are qualities?
Part of the system?
Yes.
So this is when you have your like brute force
code, you're like gross but I'm going to massage
it back into the design system or the naming
conventions that you're using.
Users' algorithm.
Does it take advantage of the intrinsic algorithms
baked into CSS?
So, like CSS Grid algorithms.
Intentional cascade.
I like this one because I love the cascade.
How can I use the cascade.
Let's use it.
To do comments.
They're not all going to be gone, but a lot
will be.
Small note here: this is kind of to me.
We all write CSS differently our teams, write
it differently, so these are some qualities
of optimised CSS that I should shoot for.
A little bit of code here.
And preface it with a yellow light, because,
as this code is taken out of context, and
might not make entire sense smashed into a
slide.
This is the way I've followed this process
to solve a problem.
This is the solution to the ocean boxes issue.
And then we have a centring algorithm.
Finally, yeah, I failed fizz buzz now I'm
like take that, fizz buzz and CSS do it.
If anybody gets asked this in an interview,
write it in CSS.
If you're not familiar with fizz buzz, it
is a beginner algorithms questions that is
intended to stump people.
It is not very nice.
It is well meaning initially, but, I don't
know.
So, after doing all this and figuring out
this new process for writing CSS for myself,
I was like, "Did I come up with a new thing?
Could this be algorithms in CSS?"
It's like a new way of writing CSS or got
to give it a name like "algorithmic CSS"?
Or maybe "intrinsic algorithmic CSS"?
Maybe.
Then I was like hmm, haw, maybe I got better
at writing CSS!
But I think I'm interested to hear from everybody
throughout the after the conference how you
use algorithms, and if this makes sense?
I'm going to wrap up a little bit with a tip
that anybody who works in this design-to-development
process with help smooth out that process,
because, unfortunately, it is not all puppies
and kittens.
I like that expression.
Here's a designer and developer, puppy and
kitten.
I think we can use algorithms as a common
term to talk about how our designs are supposed
to respond across device sizes.
And, of course, I don't want to leave out
the designer-developer algorithms.
Yay.
So, what would this look like, this conversation?
Think about we have small screens.
Okay.
We have big screens.
We have a component here that is changing
based on the screen size.
I think in this conversation, this design
to development conversation, whether it is
just with you as one person, or with a group,
with a team, we can think about the resize
rule, so what are the resize rules?
What is the component resize rules for this
particular element?
Or, algorithm, maybe?
Try it on for size.
Here's a little example of one of my projects,
one of the agencies I worked with was doing
this already.
Okay, that's great, I'm going to put this
in my talk.
They could kind of include a description of
a component with the design for the pattern,
and I was like, "Awesome, pseudo code, done,
I don't have to do this part any more."
Because we go back to our four-step algorithms-writing
process.
Our planning, step is done now, that's great.
Here is the resulting algorithm for that little
bit of code.
Magic?
Maybe.
Yay.
Conclusion.
Here we go: okay.
If you take away one thing from this talk,
it is that iceberg metaphors are amazing.
Okay, just kidding!
I wanted it to be that the code we write is
at the tip of the iceberg here, what we see,
and how it works is all the way down there,
so it's not something we necessarily see,
and it's something we have to seek out and
try to see for ourselves and fill in those
gaps where we can, and filling in those gaps
and constructing the bottom of the iceberg,
we help the code we write be at the top more
informed and intentional.
Also, this idea for a really annoying app
that would be the mindful CSS bell, and it
will go off every 30 minutes and kind of catch
you and make sure you're not writing CSS with
a hammer and say, "Read the spec.
Do you understand what this little line of
code is doing that you're writing?"
I haven't made this app and I might not, but
it's an aid.
At the end of the day: did I bridge the gap
between CSS and computer science like I intended
to?
Well, it's a lot more like this.
We have computer science, and, within computer
science, we have CSS, and we have C++, and
we have HTML, and we have JavaScript, and
many other things, and so really, I don't
know, it's all great.
I love it.
Okay.
Yay.
Thank you, everyone!
[Cheering and Applause].
This link is linking to a blog post where
it's a very large compendium of a lot of sources
about learning how a producer works and computer
science.
Thank you all.
Looking forward to talking to you later.
[Applause]